the Kansas troll is back last time we
heard from the Kansas troll he called in
live and a trend attempted to troll us
and I allowed him to give me the best he
had and he face-planted and we didn't
hear from him broke for a couple months
and now he's back this time with a poem
delivered by voice mail which uses the
word cut to little Jewboys slime balls
on my screen which only decided is
extremely obscene patreon of the white
man is their complex blue code
philosophy did their context virtue
signaling upon a smug face pastel
colored shirts the two gays embrace one
appears as a lesbian he is a beta kook
the other is a [ __ ] boy with the lips
of a duck not interesting what format
poem is that do we know like I know it's
not haiku I think of limerick I'm not
very good with us it's rhyming couplets
I think it's like a standard thing uh so
it's just I mean like you're not Jewish
so that's not a nun or gay you're not
gay I'm not gay a pastel shirts yes
sometimes there are pastel shirts on the
show I mean my lips are pretty big I
think I was a latter person that he was
I don't know who the duck lips are I
don't have me that is you know and and
yeah anyway so okay glad that he had a
while to put that together because the
live adherents did not go well for the
kansas troll what a bonus show i have
for you today I'm out of time just trust
me folks the bonus show today is really
good sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership